2,000 years before our era, we leave Mesopotamia and move to the Nile Valley.
Let's take a quick trip in time to see what went on there.
Yes, things are running normally.
Cities have been walled in.
Their walls weren't able to hold back the massive influx of a people whom we call the Indo-Europeans
for lack of a better idea of where they came from.
These people would sweep across the Orient into Central Europe.
At the moment, Hammurabi, king of Babylon, ruled Mesopotamia and dictated her laws.
As we can see, the sun god Seamus handed down the civilized world's first legal code to Hammurabi
in a very personal way. The year is 1750 before our era. If a man wrongfully curses another,
he shall be put to death. There are three kinds of men. The slaves, petty, finally, men. If a man
has debts, he may lend out his wife as repayment, but for a maximum of three years. Careless housewives
are thrown into the river. If a man's wife is seen by another, then she must throw herself into the
river. If a woman commits adultery, her lover and both shall be thrown by Abraham. The Israelite
left Ur and headed towards Canaan. The Achaeans from Mycena attacked Crete, whose civilization was
not to their taste. Under Ramses II, Egypt shone with glory. This young pharaoh dispatched the
first war communique by describing his near-defeated Kadesh as a great victory. Not long
after, the Israelites left Egypt, and with them, they took their belief in one god. In 1100 BC,
the Dorians invaded, armed with invincible iron. The Assyrians, in turn, became more warlike. By
1100 B.C., Tyre, Sidon, and Byblos were the capitals of Phoenician prosperity.
Their clever merchants succeeded in bringing west their culture and their alphabet, the one we use today.
Syria came into its own at last.
The city of Asher ruled the Middle East.
Sargon, Sennacherib, and Ashurbanipal terrorized their subjects.
On his deathbed, the bloodthirsty Ashurbanipal had this to say.
I have done no evil in the sight of God or men.
No evil?
One look at the evidence, gouged out eyes, cut off heads.
would indicate that evil was his steady diet.
612 BC, the Medes and the Babylonians are now allies.
Led by Nebuchadnezzar, they lay siege to the city of Nineveh.
Prophesied that Yahweh would make Nineveh as dry as a desert.
Nezzar turned the ruins of Babylon into the most important city of its time.
Come closer, come and see my pottery, hear ye.
Five beautiful plates, bowls and pottery.
And over here, we have the world's best dirt and rare.
Zarathustra preached in the city of wealth, but who came to hear what he had to say?
Zarathustra taught that a wise and good man doesn't do to others what he wouldn't have done to himself, but who wanted to listen?
Each man is his own judge, and can choose between good and evil, he said.
But still, no one paid any attention.
One day, Confucius would listen, and Jesus.
The young Persian prince Cyrus was educated at Zarathustra's school,
and when he decided to take the throne from his dull-witted cousin, Astyages the Mede,
His methods were well thought out.
Oh, I'm so sorry, cousin. I do hope I haven't hurt you.
But, but, but...
Can I light it now?
Uh-huh.
Couldn't I light it up for you, your majesty?
What?
That's disgusting!
As Zarathustra taught, make friends of your enemies.
Nebuchadnezzar was succeeded by Nabonidus, whose son Balthazar was not exactly loved by the people.
Put up!
Balthazar, out of the way, Nabonidus left the city to take up his new post as provincial governor.
Once Babylon was conquered, all of Mesopotamia came under Cyrus' control.
Jews were now free to return to Jerusalem and rebuild their temple.
Cyrus returned the remains of their treasures stolen under Nebuchadnezzar.
The Israelites to whom he spoke in Yahweh's name thought of him as their Messiah.
For the first time in history, conquered cities were not looted, their inhabitants left unharmed, and a conqueror showed clemency.
It was the birth of the world's first empire.
Smyrdas, the magus, an imposter, usurped the Persian throne, and seven of the royal princes decided to eliminate him.
His horse, whinnied first, would have to carry out the task.
And so, we come to Darius.
Decide to whinny.
This is Darius the first.
There was rebellion throughout the land.
Darius took a firm stand against it.
I can't fight for you.
Bash him for crying out loud.
Oh, ah, ah.
Exhausted.
Put him in the barn and take care of him.
We'll see what we can do about that.
Yes?
Master, someone is here for you.
Please come quickly.
very important visitors here.
Peters from Lebanon, teak from India, gold from Sardis, lapis lazuli from Sogdiana, turquoise,
silver, lead from Egypt, Ethiopian and Indian ivory, stone columns from Korea, Ionian stone
cutters, Lydian goldsmiths, Babylonian bricklayers, decorators.
At Persopolis, Darius the Great built himself the Palace of Marvel, twenty kingdoms.
In the history of mankind, there had never been power to equal his.
Prices are pouring in better than usual.
Here on the road to the capital, we see 500 Babylonian boys destined to become eunuchs, 400 mules, 100,000 sheep.
The cavalier think he was born on horseback.
A friend finally gets around to the reason for his visit.
Prince has raised a band of outlaws. They're fleecing the region.
The king has put me in charge of maintaining law and order.
He's setting up camp with my troops in the fortress on the hill.
So if you ever need help, you know where to find us.
what would you like dear you're gonna get hurt if you fall the band of outlaws has just attacked
the caravan we rode to their rescue the bandits outnumbered us and we're the only ones there
there they are away you suppose my boy could have disappeared too it's him all right my boy's even
broke my horse you bought the old block that one my friend i can see that there's something the
matter i'm afraid it's my boy he's extremely ill i'm afraid he might die if so what's the good of
all i know is it come along nice oh come must you leave right away what if the bandits return what
battle plan do you have for that might as well show you my battle plan you'll begin by lighting
up a good fire your weapon will be a utensil like this one oh no problem child play that's all this
is the way you must proceed huh and if those bandits should ever attack again it's simple
look closely boys you see smoke makes good signals when compressed and released a lookout could see
See them from the fortress and sound the alarm.
That's genius!
That's fantastic!
What do you do with all this stuff, my son?
Son, I'm going to show you.
It's for the construction of our capital, Persepolis.
Little drawing, my son, is a blueprint, you know.
This is known as a sundial.
Enables man to determine what time it is by noting the sun's height in the sky.
One moment, if you please.
One more time, sir?
This morning, the mark is here.
At midday, over there.
And there tonight.
Master, his majesty awaits you.
Oh dear, never a moment's peace.
We'll have to go on with this a bit later, son.
Time flies.
Hello, young Pierre.
It was Darius himself who had ordered his servant to say,
Remember Athens at mealtime.
The emperor grew fed up with hearing it.
He decided to invade Greece as a punishment for her many rebellions against him.
It was another case of Goliath versus David.
To Darius came Xerxes.
After Xerxes, Artaxerxes.
There were great battles.
Marathon, Thermopylae, Salamis.
No one was winning, so a truce was called.
And within one century, a 20-year-old conqueror would return the Persians' visit.
His name was Alexander the Great.
On the tomb of Darius were written these words,
Erase nothing, destroy nothing.
34 B.C., victory at Granicus.
333 B.C., another victory at Isis.
Since access to Persia was open to him, Alexander ignored her on purpose and besieged Tyre and Gaza.
Then he headed for Egypt.
According to Alexander, he had to go to Egypt to pay homage to his father.
he really believe he was descended from the god Amon, as his mother so often claimed? A strange,
disturbing boy, that Alexander. 331 B.C. brought the victory when Darius III was defeated once again,
and for the last time. The gates of Babylon were thrown open, and the people welcomed Alexander as
they had once welcomed Darius. He came to offer magnificent gifts to the young conquerors of
intricate design and astrologists to explain his art. The position of the stars is calculated
precisely. Alexander was troubled. His father, though handsome and intelligent, was a drinker
known for his short-lived, violent passions. His mother, a compulsive liar, never missed a chance
to humiliate her royal husband, especially on the subject of their son, who she insisted was a son
of the gods and not of man. So it's not surprising that Alexander was hot-headed, given to depressions
and to excesses, perhaps even to patricide. He was brilliant, certainly, but also a strange and
troubled man. No, you are not a god. The gods act alone, but that can't be the case with you,
For you came to the throne thanks to the Macedonians.
The nerve!
After 10 years of campaigning, there were men who had marched 20,000 kilometers and wanted a rest.
Well, I ordered this army to report immediately to the throne.
Once back in Babylon, utterly exhausted and probably sick with malaria, Alexander died at age 33.
In his brief lifetime, he had achieved his dream to unite Greece and Persia to combine the ancient East with dynamic Europe.
This intermingling of cultures would spring the Roman Empire.